aujourd'hui on va faire un toc toc toc
toc toc toc c'est très simple puisque tu
es une star du x très sympa les
chroniqueurs ont envie de te rendre
hommage en se transformant en acteur x
ringard donc à chaque fois tu vas voir
je vais dire qui est là et moyens par
exemple un métier et le la et après vous
faire une chanson
t'as rien compris moi non plus c'est pas
la honte en mer devrait avec ça tu suite
ayant des noms d'origine italienne
encore est d'origine italienne tu viens
d'où en italie à bellucci boutonnat au
retour c'est l'autre côté de
l'adriatique dalle led adriatique
l'autre côté de rome
bien sûr la robe et de l'autre côté il
ya un gros asiatiques orton brotchi
l'autre brucci abrutis blood site abrite
sur blood si aboutie
bah quoi tu aurais tu aurais peut-être
dû naître là bas a abouti à l'est des
parties premier toc toc toc on y va d'un
moteur plus tard quand les mecs déjà on
va pas et va baisser d'un ton le gars il
tape à la porte on dirait que tu vas
chez tes voisins parce qu'ils ont faim
tapage nocturne
ouais refait le toc toc toc ça met
l'accent est confus qui hélas très
plombier le pont de vic le plombier qui
premier l'a jamais appliquée
[Applaudissements]
la cheville chanter
[Musique]
benjamin castaldi il paraîtrait des
primes de siphon non merci n'en a pas
c'est monsieur la célébrer notre
regardez regardez ça vingt ans de
carrière
eh oui non mais son usage et voici ces
inconscients ce que j'aime
mais la basse jean marie je prends pas
la tête il est toujours la peau bravo
mon frérot tchèque je t'aime bayrou
regardez c'est costaud ça c'est qu'on
aurait perdu un peu ça fait de la
musculation week-end un peu
non maintenant je peux voir pour toi
bats cause de ma jambe ah ouais d'accord
et web a lui aussi il a une jambe qui
[Rires]
boite et tous les deux mais pas pour les
mêmes raisons
[Applaudissements]
oui moi on sait très bien que ces
abonnements immostat on a compris à
auxon au son de la boit on sait ok là
c'est le boulanger
excusez moi vous n'avez pas prévu une
voix quelque chose c'est le boulanger
bon alors vous savez ce que vous faites
non vous repartez vous travaillez votre
personnage vous venez ok merci bat
bourgoin brico votre personnage sera
travaillée merci aller 3è toc toc toc
toc toc toc
j'ai tout de suite vu ça rigolait j'ai
vu au bruit j'ai vu que c'était
quelqu'un de délicats à octobre stocks
qui hélas randonneurs le ramoneur qui
remet honneur la coupe à la maison
[Applaudissements]
ayrault je sais que tu es mon ami ait
pas besoin de te déguiser 1
j'étais comme ça toute la journée moi je
m'en faire mais ils sont d es mes frères
il tombe pas des grilles seront déguisés
en remplaça ramoneur way savez gérer un
ramoneur commence dans les années 1900
c'est vrai parce que ces mecs dans les
champs les films érotiques
moi je me rappelle je regardais le film
érotique d'm6 à l'époque avec les
copains je me rappelle et on regardait
comme ça et ce qui nous énerve et à
chaque fois c'est que faisait comme ça
c'est la pub on appelle ça m'énervait
mon père est et c'est vrai ces intrigues
ou pourquoi il ya toujours des métiers
un peu chelou parce que forcément dans
les films érotiques ce qu'on connaît
c'est toujours à chaque fois le mec
arrive seria ramoneur et à l'oeil à
colombier toi tu as fait des rôles comme
ça bien sûr tu as fait quoi toi comme
all un peu tout ça au début tu as fait
de ramoneur à de but au début oui au
début on est obligé de passer par la
coiffe tout au début tu vois ton
concevoir ramoneur ok c'est bon donc tu
chauffeur de la limousine ya le pompiste
steve motta fin xo message est presque
tout vu mais vous savez qui en fait
l'ailé version érotique c'est en fait
les versions coupé des versions
pornographie alors je vais vous dire la
différence une version porno est une
version érotique ce que j'ai beaucoup
étudié le sujet pour un master voilà que
j'ai fait avec jésus une maîtrise et
llodra la différence c'est que dans un
film porno tu vois les zizis dans un
film érotique tu ne vois pas ouais en
fait ils coupent les zizis il voit juste
besoin d'une série en fait dans les
films dans les films érotiques à un
rabbin qui arrivent comme pour couper
les gigis voilà c'est tout c'est simple
on rigolait ya juste une circoncision de
fait on ne voit jamais un zizi sur un
film érotique dans mesrine
c'est ça qui ont faim ont coutume de
confiance oui tu as fais des films
érotiques touba en passant par des films
ardossi coupe d'afrique au pays confie
le wll double version je pense que la
mer ce n'est pas exact
première de factures et toc toc toc
monima c'est quelqu'un de très longues
octobre toc
voilà sur la tête de ma mère ne dit pas
qui c'est sur la vie de ma mère juste au
toc toc toc c'est doc gynéco base et ap
mais non ça peut peut-être pourquoi t'as
pas répondu
[Applaudissements]
saurez vous les imaginez au capital et 3
coups t'imagines avant de jouer les
acteurs et en battant les trois coups de
doc gynéco faire manger ces deux coups
ses atouts
valero table tu peut être pas lui est ce
que j'ai donné je suis mauvaise langue à
l'hérésie trop tard c'est lui c'est fort
octobre ce qui est la meilleure
il sera remis aux normes y aller comme
assad qui est là c'est trop le dock le
dock qui vient
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
juste une question toute bête tu très
contente de voir que mon ami tu as
compris le principe de la séquence
oui oui tu as bien je suis censé entrer
oui c'est ça par cette porte là va
effectivement m'asseoir et entre les
deux un truc il se passe quoi n'a pas
compris la séquence en fait mais c'était
très bien quand même
si si je crois que j'ai compris je le
projet devait passer là je vais arriver
je vais danser un peu non
pourquoi mon boulot est bien voir le
docteur nom n'est pas peur ou bien toi
et je vous dis les filles sont
magnifiques ce soit dans ses magnifiques
pas tout
merci 6 6 à 6 non aux castrats d'italie
j'ai dit pas tout
pourquoi pas tout bas parce que
certaines moins que les autres alors ses
arômes sortie aller bartois la mac gyver
de simon lamarre toile à magali c'est à
moi que tu parles
oui ça alors je vais arrêter parce que
tu es là il m'a cassé la jambe dh dont
on t'embrasse correcte j'ai dit que
j'étais gentil avec toi tu peux te
remettre à denis barthe aux attaques
montbard touché mon talent énorme mais
il va me faire mal soir à gaza comme
quoi tu as eu peur c'est ça
allez toc toc toc tac tac tac je vous
entends pas toc toc toc on a branché son
micro voilà c'est juste une tranche à
monter ce que là je sais que c'est ben
haim elle ne fait pas que c'est que la
télé également tpm paix il faut pas lui
enlever son micro code obtenu la
médaille mais qu'est ce que tu veux et
la terre oui qu'est ce que vous voulez
la secrétaire qui la secrétaire jean
landes
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
une scène va faire une scène bonjour
bonjour vous êtes la secrétaire tout à
fait vous avez rendez vous avec les
médecins oui j'ai rendez vous avec un
certain docteur le docteur qu'aux cas
c'est ce que l'on va faire
oui paraît que c'est un docteur aux
méthodes peu orthodoxes
vous voyez ce que je veux dire house est
un monsieur hanouna
mais je suis à 100 avec un h comme un
animal
[Applaudissements]
très crédible très crédible je veux
faire d'essais avec tout le monde bien
commun ou encore tu penses que je ferai
un bon acteur os x comme ça il peut pas
avoir un look
t'as le look mais t'as pas ladite
allenou moi je vais te la mettre sur la
tête varité colisée tma-21 j'étais manu
et tu auras j'étais dans la bouche tu me
diras tu à dire papa de noix deux mois
du pagne à trop dur où on a fait ça
c'est compliqué quand on entend ça en
cm2 il ya que des rôles ou comme ça un
territoire syrien
leur ton n'est pas pour villard de l'anc
sont allés oliva alesi toc toc toc toc
toc toc à ski est là c'est jean-michel
mais qui a laissé coi a laissé coi tueur
en direct je rentre en direct par en
direct rend le direct
merci on l'a qui voit là l'inspecteur
que taillon
[Applaudissements]
et c'est là qu'on voit qu'on a un rôle à
moi cité jean claude van damme si la
bagarre
ma passion contrôle d'al chouf et la
pluie des taux en tout cas ce petit
décolleté ou va ravir je sais mais on
paie les dans le monde entier y a pas à
l'endroit dans brotherhood bas on ne
connaît pas rocco siffredi dans le monde
entier les tacles ans et voulait
vraiment parler tout de suite vous les
donnez lui un chocolat chaud un truc
pour ailier les langues
merci à les toc toc toc toc toc qui est
là c'est la maîtresse fort qu'elle
mettrait sa la maîtresse ce qui mettrait
sommet
ouais
les
je parle
[Applaudissements]
m
bonjour bonjour chers en maîtresse
attention je tape qu'on ne connaît pas
et jouent en réponse vous avez l'air
dans le monde sévère
[Applaudissements]
bonjour je sais que voilà je suis là
mais pour finir il aime parents d'élèves
paraît-il que vous êtes extrêmement
sévère
sévère sur ma part à main je ne connais
pas la racine au carré de 16 vous la
montrer vous allez vous montrez votre
wii vous me montrez moi donc que votre
peau sinus il a gardé ma règle la
rencontre il prend des notes
les toc toc toc toc toc toc eau qui est
là c'est la banquière la bonne quiero
qui banquière le droit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
ça
[Applaudissements]
bonjour madame la banquière salut
jurançon j'ai reçu un email alors pari
si le jeu serait à découvert
[Rires]
ce matin oui j'ai étudié vos comptes au
oui/non beaucoup plus oui ils sont
stimulants ah oui excitant ils sont à
moi vous savez on me dit que j'ai plus
d'actifs que de passif
si vous voyez ce que je veux dire à la
banquière vous voulez que je vous donne
un rib relevé d'identité demain les
jurés ne vais pas travailler ça c'est
naturel c'est incroyable ce coup ci
[Applaudissements]
merci j'ai envie merci d'être là oui
alors oui ah oui alors allez-y c'est une
autre ambiance franchement et l'autre
lui demande
non mais sans rire on lui demande d'être
sexy l'hôtellerie toc toc toc aussi
camionneurs c'est quand même un monde
refait le var travailler ton personnage
si bassir en bois - grabels et gilles on
va annuler parce que je suis pas choqué
a plus ça m'angoisse ans sa femme en
bois ça roule vers le mettra sur
facebook lite
isabelle oui intacte mais bon c'est que
c'est vous qui est là c'est le boulanger
ont pas le miche à la retravailler sur
wii le bouchon à merde j'ai la capitale
soyons bien avec moi dans la nuit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est elle qui a mangé le goût à la
rouve est ce arrivé au bout de ma mère y
avait trois baguettes au départ un truc
d'eau elle devait rentrer avec six
bogeys là encore 5 minutes de plus à
l'est c'est un pruneau bravo quand même
prometteur vous êtes très jolie comme ça
vous avez une très belle toc toc
alé lô badis et qui met d'abord d'abord
tac tac tac
voilà c'est mieux qui hélas ni l'autre
et la selo tasse à l'hôtesse qui
[Musique]
obama
[Applaudissements]
ouah
bonsoir pressé le fort
pour savoir murray et sincères excuses
moi l'ate normalement tu le sens en
avoir vous avez de la famille de doc
gynéco battu voix bonsoir
bon ça alors ça ben arous espoirs va se
retrouver dans un instant gil pète
bethune très rapide merci